with practice self-reflection along with
a little bit of guidance we can all hone
our communication skills i'm matt
abrahams and i teach communication at
stanford graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today we will focus on the idea of
communication mastery with my friend
colleague and mentor jd shrom who in
addition to lecturing in strategic
communication was also recently named
the director of the king global
leadership program for the knight
hennessey scholars program at stanford
when we originally recorded our
conversation i had a cold so please
pardon my voice
welcome jd thanks matt thanks for having
me now i know you have a new book coming
out on the topic of communication
mastery called communicate with mastery
speak with conviction and write for
impact so i guess that's a great place
for us to start
how do you define mastery i love the
definition of mastery that dan pink
gives in his book drive
mastery is getting better and better at
something that matters
for you for me for many leaders that we
have the privilege of working with
communication is something that matters
and
you cannot
reach perfection in communication no
matter how great the document is how
great the speech is
how concise the report is you still
could always make it just a little bit
better
and so we look at mastery as being an
aspiration that i get closer and closer
and closer
but i never get to perfection
and that that's the the premise of the
book is how can i iterate over time and
keep getting better and better and
better
knowing that the goal is something i
will never fully reach and that's part
of the process that we go through
and it seems to me that the work that
you do to get toward to achieve mastery
is really in and of itself the benefit
and the reward it's not
mastery itself it's the effort towards
mastery is that right
it is and i think if if a leader can be
self-reflective
and
recognize that the growth that they have
had
over a period of time
it is that that process that is
really accelerating and really
encouraging
much more than the product of
that one talk or that one deck or that
one letter
you know that notion of reflection
self-reflection that you mentioned i
think is so critical to success in any
communication but especially as we
strive for mastery i'm curious if you
have any insights and thoughts about
adjusting and adapting your
communication to the needs of the people
you're speaking to
well two thoughts on that one
i think it's crucial that leaders
deliver the message the audience needs
to hear
more than the message the leader wants
to share and so i think we have to be
very to be effective as a leader we've
got to be very
audience centric
in the way in which we design and
deliver communication
and
we have to be really careful as we're
reading an audience
we could misinterpret something we could
get something wrong
thinking that they're bored with us and
they're actually so intent on it or
thinking that they're so intent on that
they're bored by what we're doing
so in the in the design of the
communication i have to really think
about my audience a lot in the delivery
i want to be sensitive to the audience
but i also want to acknowledge i don't
have all the information so if i'm going
to invent or interpret what's going on
for somebody interpret something that's
going to support me and encourage me
like their intent on what i'm saying
rather than assuming oh they're bored by
what i'm saying so there's kind of
something different in the delivery than
in the design but we have to be
thoughtful about the audience throughout
just don't over correct or over respond
on something we're making up while we're
speaking i really like that distinction
of what you do going into the creation
of the content being in service of the
audience but then in the moment of
delivery
it's a different perspective
you know i'm smiling as you tell that
story about the audience and not reading
right what's happening i once had a
student who the whole time i'm speaking
he's nodding his head i thought oh my
goodness we are connecting here
what happened though is when he dropped
his pen he was wearing a hoodie and i
saw he had earbuds in he wasn't paying
attention to a darn word i was saying so
your advice of what you see is not
always what you get is is very very true
you know i want to get back to this
notion of design because we've talked a
bit about designing messages for
audiences but one thing i appreciate so
much about the work you do is you really
spend time championing
the establishment of what i'll call a
positive communication culture within an
organization and i believe and i think
you believe as well that part of what a
leader does is not only communicate well
and model good communication but
establishes a culture of communication
now i have to tell you jd one of the
reasons i'm excited about your book is
that i know you are a collector of
examples and anecdotes and stories and
slides both good and not so good
and i look forward to seeing which ones
you've chosen and whenever i need an
example of something you are the first
person i come to
can you share a few examples that you
think highlight best practices or
perhaps practices to be avoided as
people progress towards their own
communication mastery i love that
question matt
so there's a section in the book
that is all about
communicating from a particular
perspective or point of view or
orientation
and
the groups that i chose to highlight in
there
communicating as an lgbtq leader as a
member of the gay community i've done a
lot of work in that and so there's a
section on what's distinct about being
an out lgbt leader there's a section uh
honed especially from the work of
allison kluger and stephanie solaire on
executive presence for women and what
are the best resources out there what
are some of the resources out there to
avoid that are not what we would want
but in that section i also have
communicating as a military veteran
and through both the ignite program here
and the brake line program
we've been able to work with veterans
who are going from a life of military
service to a career in the civilian
ranks
and many of the veterans who are in the
ignite program here were very generous
with me as i wrote that and researched
that and came up with tips and stories
about
what that transition is like
and i don't know
that there are very many resources out
there that look at that
slice of communication whether it's it's
somebody who's been marginalized or
somebody who has had a distinct uh
service experience and how can i how can
i approach mastery when i've got this
experience which may be an asset or
maybe a liability but i just have to
acknowledge that's what i'm coming into
the conversation with and those stories
were awesome to get to collect and then
to share back out to the men and women
of the military who who fed into that
and have them
respond to it they were grateful to see
something like codified in one place
it's exciting to me to know that your
book not only will give general
guidelines and advice
but also targets very
specific experiences people have and how
they themselves can then work on their
own personal mastery
are there any specific tools and
exercises you recommend people try as
they journey towards communication
mastery there are several uh let me
limit it to just
two
and this again goes back to the concept
of iteration getting better and better
at something we include in the in the
book and cara levy who's a communication
coach here at the gsb was my co-author
on this
we include a lot of examples of how to
self-edit your writing it is always
useful for me to hand over an email or
report to somebody else to copy edit or
be a a check for me does this hit the
right tone does this the right level of
detail for this audience but how can i
do that when i don't have somebody to
turn a document over to
similarly in the oral communication
being able to use our smartphones
effectively to record our side of a
conversation and analyze it later
to be able to hand our phone to somebody
in a business meeting and say when i do
my pitch to senior management could you
just subtly
capture it on video or even just on
audio that is completely unobtrusive in
a meeting then i can go back i can hear
exactly what i said i can look at the
fillers i can look at the up talk i can
look at the long-winded sentences or
where did the questions come and being
able to use just simple tools like that
in small ways we get better and better
at what we're doing it doesn't have to
be hiring a coach and doing you know
hours of rehearsal to get ready for a
ted talk it can literally be something
as simple as
reviewing a document after i've written
it or
audio recording a conversation that i
had and then analyzing my side of it
it comes back to that review and
reflection that we talked about a little
earlier you know and many people forget
that virtual tools like webex and zoom
and skype they all have record features
and you can record yourself and take the
time to watch and listen and you can
learn painful but very very helpful
now jd i have to admit something to you
uh i'm very jealous of many things that
take place in your life but your book
collection
is
beyond compare and and i have tried in
my best way to compete but you have an
amazing book collection you are very
well read in our field and beyond i'm
curious what are you reading currently
and and how is it applying to what you
do
two books that are in my current orbit
one is a book that deloitte produced
called business chemistry the author is
kim christ fort
and it's similar to
mbti
or enneagram
any strengthsfinder so you take an
assessment and it comes up with one of
four styles an integrator a pioneer a
driver or a guardian
easy words to remember and then it it
not only tells you
what your practices are and what your
weaknesses are but if i'm a driver how
do i interact with an integrator if i'm
an integrator how do i interact with a
guardian so it's really good about
inter-team communication as well as
knowing myself so that one i'm very
excited about i've been learning more
and more about it may even teach a
course about this in the future and then
the second one people who know me a huge
fan of storytelling with data by cole
cannot flick nusbomber and she has a
second book coming out that's activities
for storytelling with data and it's it's
a workbook it's almost like having coal
at your side helping you think through
the charts and graphs that you create
how are you going to design them and how
are you going to deliver them that
you're not just data dumping so those
are two of my top
top 20 right now as you were speaking i
was already looking them up on amazon
and they will be in my book collection
soon
we end every one of these podcasts with
three questions that i ask everybody and
i'd love for you to share your answers
to these three so
the first question is if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title
what would it be
you cannot
not communicate
whether i write an email or i sit back
and i wait for a day whether i speak up
in a meeting or i remain silent whether
i sigh or i smile you cannot not
communicate no matter what you do you're
communicating something so let's take
some ownership for the communication you
want out there rather than have it just
be by default what you're doing i liked
how you turned a double negative into a
positive bit of advice that was cool
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
i've got to go to the queen
oprah winfrey
her ability
to tell stories that make a point that
draw you in
i've gotten to see her present in person
twice
i spoke at a conference that she was one
of the keynotes and and being able to
hear her in person
describe and inspire people to be their
best selves hands down i just think she
is
top of her game and for the audience
listening i think her golden globes
acceptance speech of the lifetime
achievement award two years ago
brilliant storytelling brilliant arc
great use of mantra just across the
board everything she did very effective
i 100 agree that that particular speech
was phenomenal
third question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
i'm going to fall back to something i
teach in almost every class and every
workshop
audience intent and message
mary munter and lynn russell several
years ago created the aim model
who is your audience got to know who i'm
writing or speaking to
what is my intent what do i want them to
do with that
after they receive it and only once i
know audience intent can i then create
the message the biggest mistake that
leaders make today is they jump
immediately to message without slowing
down to think about
who really needs to hear this and when
they hear it or read it what's the
action i need them to take so the three
answers to me are audience intent
message what a wonderful way to wrap up
a conversation about mastery and we all
need to slow down and think about in a
very methodical appropriate way
how we develop our communication skills
written or spoken and you've given us
great insight in our conversation and i
and i hope everyone else looks forward
to your book to give us even more
information thank you so much for being
an inspiration to me and everybody else
thank you matt it was a privilege to get
to be here thanks for doing the podcast
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts finally find us on
social media at stanford.gsb